and play
all right hey everybody we're expecting
things to get pretty wild here today
um donald trump is going to be speaking
in about 15 minutes from texas
and a lot of things have gotten very
very crazy over the last
uh 24 or so hours some of them i covered
on the program
that we've recorded that is not quite
out yet i'm seeing that my member count
has not been reset from yesterday so
let's do that
boom there we go usually you don't like
see it to see it going the wrong
direction
but in this case it is the right thing
to do
so we are expecting to hear from donald
trump in about 15 minutes that means
probably it will be within the next
hour or two but i have
plenty of things to discuss with you
between now and then people asking for
an
update on youtube subscriber numbers
including elias chavarria who sent a
super chat saying you have 900
000 subscribers on youtube keep up the
great work yes we did it
um we actually hit 900 000 during
yesterday's live stream
but it didn't roll over on socialblade
for whatever reason but we're actually
90 shy of nine uh i'm sorry we're
actually 70 shy
of 901 000 and so my goal
has been for a while to get to a million
before election day
right now we're scheduled i don't know
how well you can see this let's see if i
can zoom it in
uh that did not really help right now
we're scheduled to hit a million
on january 8th which would be before
inauguration but two months after the
election
but the numbers i've run suggest we only
need like a thousand
thirty a day to get there by election
day it is actually doable we've had a
bunch of days in the last couple of
weeks where we've had
two thousand three thousand and even
four thousand new youtube subscribers in
a day
so my my thought is like yesterday the
projection said january 9
now it says january 8th if we can keep
it up
this number may get closer and closer to
election day and what a dream it would
be to actually hit a million subscribers
on election day and i don't know
what we're going to do to celebrate yet
some people said i should dye my hair
it's like okay yeah maybe i don't really
get the point or
you know i don't know i'm open to
different ideas in the meantime
we are trying to get to 50 000 followers
on twitch where we have surpassed 40
000. of course we're much newer to
twitch
and engagement is high there and very
very exciting things are happening
happening there um so we're not uh
foregoing any platform and by the way
this is actually crazy very quietly we
just started
a show instagram page like not my
personal instagram but the show
instagram not that long ago
we're regularly posting video clips to
igtv
a lot of our clips on igtv are getting
40 50 000 views
which is insane like that's becoming a
bigger and bigger
platform for us so we're uh we're doing
it all it's um
we're not uh discriminating in any sense
in favor of or against anybody
mark fillion said i don't think biden
needs to do press conferences trump is
easily digging his own grave on its own
money saved for the democrats yeah today
on the bonus show we actually had a
conversation about how i don't care
whether there's a convention i don't i
almost don't care who biden's vp is
assuming it's not someone cartoonishly
terrible and i
don't even really need biden to do press
conferences i mean it's just
it's never been as cut and dry um as it
is right now
i want to say thank you to tara
steinschnider who is new member number
one today
at joinpackman.com.com hey tara very
much appreciate your support
i do have an updated bingo card which i
will show you
in a bit um what else did i want to go
over
oh uh do we want to do this so
louis gomer has caught covered
call it what you want and he's against
wearing masks like for example here he
is yesterday at william barr's hearing
walking out right behind bars barr has
no or before the hearing
bar has no mask gomer has no mask
he now has the virus and he thinks he
may have caught it
i guess during some brief moment during
which he wore
he thinks the mask may have gave given
him the virus
i can't help but wonder if by keeping a
mask
on and keeping it in place that
if i might have uh put
some germs some fire some of the virus
on a virus
that's got how many a's are in virus
under the mask and breathed it in
i don't know but i got it we'll see what
happens from here
but the reports of my demise are very
premature
premature yeah um so he go he refuses to
wear a mask
at some point i guess he had to put one
on and he thinks that brief moment
may have been where he got the virus
like
this is how stupid people are that that
live in this country
uh and actually this guy used to be a
judge if you can imagine
then i have video i don't know if you
guys want to see this trump bragged
about his reading comprehension
and it's like it stopped being funny a
long time ago
um and you know i know many adults who
know how to read
and when they read stuff they understand
it not a single one of them has ever
said to
me my reading comprehension's really
good um
they just know how to read they're just
adults right they usually focus on what
are you doing with the information
here's trump telling axios reporter i'll
just play it for you guys
here's a trump saying his reading
comprehension is better
maybe better than anyone that jonathan
swann has interviewed and it's like
why are the reading comprehension
abilities of people
this guy has interviewed even a topic of
conversation take a listen
we had a call talking about nuclear
proliferation which is a very big
subject
where they would like to do something
and so would i we discussed numerous
things we did not discuss that now and
you've never discussed it
i have never discussed it with them now
i would i'd have no problem with it but
you don't but
you know it's never because you don't
believe the intelligence that's why uh
everything you know it's interesting
nobody ever brings up china they always
bring russia russia russia
if we can do something with russia in
terms of the proliferation which is a
very big problem
bigger problem than global warming a
much bigger problem than global warming
in terms of the real world
that would be a great thing no it never
i don't know that that's true like
we're dealing with with global warming
we're dealing with a lot of irreversible
damage
the nuclear anyway that's not even the
topic but i think he's wrong pitched my
desk
you know why because they didn't think
it was intelligence
they didn't think it was real it was in
your written life
they didn't think it was worthy of i
wouldn't mind if it reached my desk i
would have done something about it
it never reached my desk because do you
read your recent brief
i do i read it a lot you know i read a
lot they like to say i don't read i read
a lot
uh i comprehend extraordinarily well uh
probably better than anybody that you've
interviewed in a long time
i comprehend extremely well
probably better than anyone you've
interviewed in a long time have you guys
noticed how the
the topic invariably goes to the
interviewer
like when he was interviewed by chris
wallace about the cognitive test
trump said i did better you know biden
couldn't get the last questions right
and then he said to chris wallace even
you couldn't get the last questions
right it's like
why is chris wallace's cognitive ability
at issue
here it's i comprehend really well
and i comprehend better than anyone
you've interviewed in a long time like
what what
what relevance does who jonathan swann
from axios has interviewed ha i mean
it's
it's crazy so we're going to dig into
this in detail tomorrow
and trump during this clip bending over
backwards as usual
to not to to defend not criticizing or
confronting vladimir putin and you don't
need to have any russia conspiracy to to
point out
like trump just seems enamored with
putin it doesn't
have to be more than that it can just be
you know the right likes to talk about
oh
you guys went too far with the russia
thing the russia gate
all this stuff trump seems enamored with
authoritarians
putin at the top of the list that's it
like you don't there might be more there
but you don't have to make a case that
there's more he just seems to be going
out of his way to explain
why he doesn't confront putin about
this that or the other thing so that's
that we're going to dig into that more
tomorrow
but today we're standing by for donald
trump just minutes from now
in texas he is going to presumably take
some questions and make some kind of
propaganda statement in texas
if you are just joining on youtube make
sure to hit that subscribe button we are
now on the path to a million subscribers
hoping
by election day we're at 901 000 right
now 99 one down 99 to go
um i haven't you do you guys want to do
the bingo card now or should i do super
chats what do people want
take a sip here
or super chats i could do one or the
other um in the meantime
thanks to sva for subscribing over on
twitch i appreciate that very much
uh looks like it's kind of a split
people leaning towards bingo okay let's
do the bingo card now that that's fine
but first let me thank a few people
who have signed up natalie krall jeremy
ritchie
and um jeg bird
our new members two three and four today
so that gets us to
four at joinedpakman.com okay so people
have started up
a david pakman show um
bingo card and yesterday i displayed it
for you and there were some
elements on it that weren't great so i
said email me replacements
and i will pull the less good items and
replace them and we'll keep iterating so
hopefully
like we'll identify what are the worst
items on this bingo card and then people
can email me through my website
other ideas and we'll keep improving and
eventually this is going to be really
really good
so we'll go through them here's what we
have left right now from the standpoint
of yes i do say that
i'm kind of mimicking trump it's not
really my thing but i do say that
sometimes as a joke
uh caught the caller i'm talking to a
caller and the call drops that's
frequent
here's a new one from yesterday
massachusetts is handling the virus well
i'll zoom this in a little bit for us
massachusetts handling the virus well i
do say that i am proud of how
massachusetts has dealt with the virus
so far
and we you know for for day weeks now
we've had only 200
um 200 cases a day so i do mention that
i deliberately pronounce a name
incorrectly that does happen so i think
that should definitely be there
i'm talking to a caller who sounds as if
they're underwater that is surprisingly
common
i use the term can you imagine i make a
hard
sell membership pitch there's a
clickbaity youtube title i use the
phrase
elements of blank again that's me
copying trump but it's fine to have it
i espouse an opinion unpopular with
progressives
that sometimes happens i use the term
with peace and love yep
so with peace and love is a way to
soften a criticism like if a call
i got it from ringo starr if a caller
calls in
and they make no sense whatsoever i'll i
want to tell them i don't know
what the f you're talking about but
instead i'll say listen i'm saying this
with total peace and love
i don't know what you're talking about
with peace and love and the idea is you
kind of soften it it's almost like
saying with all due respect
um caller asks is that me and i say yes
it is that's frequent
weapon referring to things as weaponized
accidentally hit my mic
you know since i got the new microphone
it's much more compact so i think that
the mic hits are going to be less
frequent
i mentioned going to a cafe or a coffee
shop a lot of my stories
start with that as a catalyst that's
true i offer an absurd
and possibly illegal membership discount
that's frequent
that's actually frequent i run my
fingers through my hair
the caller is either exercising or using
heavy machinery
unfortunately that's also really common
i mentioned being from argentina
i run down my personal stock holdings
i mention either my kukes or my zooks
from the garden that's going to go away
after the gardening season so that may
be just a temporary one
i refer to a caller or myself as being
shot out of a cannon
i refer to kaylee mckennany magga nanny
of course i tell a story about a current
or former producer or i use the phrase
exactly as we predicted on the show and
i love doing that but i always
i do it humbly i will say exactly as we
predicted on the show
not that there's anything special about
that everybody has been predicting this
because it's so obvious so i think that
the
humility aspect is uh is an important
one so
this is the latest bingo card and what i
would
invite you to do it's too hard to do it
in chat
um go to my website and use the contact
form
and tell me david i think you know
accidentally hits mike is not a great
square
here's an idea to replace it and i think
if we keep iterating like this within a
week or two
we're going to have a really really good
um bingo card so that's that's my ask
will we now the funny thing is will we
ever actually play with the bingo card
probably not like the fun it's it's all
about the journey
that's really the the idea let's just
keep iterating and going over and
improving the bingo card
um okay where did i leave off over here
oh if you're just joining you haven't
missed anything we're standing by
for supposedly three minutes from now
this event is going to start
let's see what we have in terms of super
chats a lot of them are coming in
um where did we leave off the vegan
villanese
says thanks for keeping us sane during
these trying times i couldn't bear to
watch these without you and your input
thank you i appreciate that
johnny minogue says hey david why is
your phone number an indiana area code
when it's been produced in new york and
massachusetts
um it's so our voicemail number is 219
to david p it's just that was what was
available we wanted to have something
related to the show
like david p it's google voice so 219
was what was available we don't have
anything to do with uh
indiana bolo turner says congratulations
on 900
000 subscribers here's to one million
mark costan dropping in out of nowhere
with a powerful fifty dollar super chat
thanks mark
robert mifflin says what do you think
about susan rice as vp is it likely
i think she's in the top three but not
the the leader is my uh assessment right
now
could i be friends with a trump
supporter theoretically
theoretically i mean i'm not but could
happen
seth barham says hi david did you see
the video of the white guy holding a
black lives matter sign in harrison
arkansas reaction from the residence was
disturbing i didn't see that
seth no tyler asks have i looked at
kodak stock
up approximately sixteen hundred percent
unfortunately fujifilm
was not as lucky because every everyone
was trying to buy fuji film yeah that's
good
let me check out um kodak stock
kodak eastman kodak
up 300 that is insane yeah trump
mentioning them yesterday
trading like at two dollars for a while
and now it's up to 33
that is absolutely insane now the weird
thing is
was it up before trump's announcement
that's weird that would raise some
interesting questions in my mind
yeah i don't know how long that's gonna
go uh
i have no opinion about that but
something about the trading volume
before trump's announcement is a little
bit
weird to me and i would uh certainly
look into that that's not funny says
david when's any trump thing
actually urgent rarely very very rarely
yeah no that's
that's a fair point arun mehta says how
long until the 12 000 troops from
germany end up as part
of trump's invasion of u.s cities it's
too scary of a coincidence in my opinion
it's all scary and you know now all of a
sudden the people who were saying
obama is going to declare martial law
suspend the election and never leave
those people are now saying there's
nothing to worry about about
the armed pal uh paramilitaries
throwing people into unmarked vans those
people
are now saying there's nothing to worry
about now
which is uh something else something
else
no hype train yet triggered on
um no hype train yet triggered on
twitch um
yeah no there's no hype train happening
right now but we are of course uh
very very closely following what's
happening on twitch for sure
bay photo says hope you hit a million
subscribers but david
be sure to watch out for the fake
mail-in subscribers yeah you know i've
read that we may have a problem of
people
subscribing twice to our youtube channel
and also dead people subscribing these
are real problems and also babies
subscribing who aren't even old enough
to subscribe so
we want to get a clean million i don't
want a million where like 11 000 are
fake
we want a totally clean million
subscribers
michael fitz says hey david my wife and
i love watching your show and love how
you fact check in real time keep up the
good work thanks michael
zachary foster says david you should
have seen the ridiculous nonsensical
tech illiterate questions
the people on the committee asked today
at the big tech hearing
uh from what i think jim sensenbrenner
asked
mark zuckerberg why something happened
on twitter
and zuckerberg was like you know i run
facebook i don't know
uh and i think that there was a moment
where so there was a previous
this was not today but someone asked
i think it was uh the ceo of google
why an iphone works a certain way or
something it was
really really weird like it just didn't
didn't make any sense
thanks to phil f30 for subscribing with
twitch prime you are new your twitch
subscriber 786
and no lad has subscribed with prime
your subscriber
787 that's a plane i've not stepped on
to for a while given that i've gone
you know nowhere for quite some time
thanks to leann o'neal who's new member
number five today at joinedpakman.com
and matthew ferguson who is new member
number six today
at joinpackman.com um we are standing by
here for donald trump scheduled for two
minutes ago
um not much yet happening but presumably
he won't start super late uh
sam kimpton has also subscribed with
prime which i very much appreciate
we're already almost at a level two hype
train and indeed now we are which is
happening very very quickly
uh zesty african says via super chat
where are the pro-gun sycophants that
claimed the sole purpose of their gun
ownership
was to defend against the government
encroaching on the rights of the
vulnerable
uh whoops just lost my earpiece they are
tweeting
in support of the armed paramilitaries
that's where they are right now
shocking i know danny thompson says
david i have a dream i dream of setting
up my own youtube channel
where my only content is videos of me
reacting to
you from these live streams grandma has
to ha a grandma
has to have her dreams lol yes i very
much agree
with that i think i have um a reaction
video that some of you may have seen
uh oh no i don't i don't have it
oh hold on wait a second do i have it on
my desktop here
i don't have there's a really funny
video of a viewer's mom reacting to me
accidentally clapping the other day when
i was just gesticulating
and it's really funny but i actually
don't have it available for you right
now
my apologies ron says biden didn't vote
for the iraq war the vote was to
authorize military action
and force iraq to allow weapons
inspectors
bush told the inspectors to leave and
attacked iraq
five months later ron wow
coming in out of nowhere elias chavarria
says whoops where did that go uh the
incoming flu season combined with covet
19
is going to be a disaster this fall is
my first semester of college and the
situation scares me i feel terribly for
people starting college right now
it just seems like a horrible horrible
time to be starting college
and um i do not envy you at all
my hope is if you persevere
you will be um very very
uh powerfully rewarded in that you will
be
more resilient as a result of starting
college at this time
assuming that we don't have an explosive
spread of coronavirus
and college students start to die uh
i guess time will tell thanks to ireman
42
as well as house b suck and why am i
sticky
geez who are all participating in a hype
train that is approaching level three
thanks to chiroshi as well very much
appreciate that
new velco says i understand why some
polls are more or less accurate but what
makes some left-leaning or right-leaning
just leading questions and is it
intentional
uh so sometimes it's a question of who's
funding it sometimes they do use leading
questions there's every combination
sometimes they oversample
uh democrats as an example blown high
spot says hey david do you think trump
really believes what that crazy doctor
has said or do you think he's trolling
fouchy
i actually don't know and i raised that
issue in a clip
um that's publishing at 5 30 eastern
so that that's a i'm wondering the same
thing you're wondering
thanks to carmen for this uh the
subscription
louis snowden says did you see musk
bolivia tweet
i did not administrator
says keep it up brent hess says that
proves that subscribe by mail is riddled
with fraud right yeah you shouldn't be
allowed to subscribe to a youtube
channel by mail you should have to do it
online i agree
wilma diekfit says david your wiki
came's your first pet was a wombat and
you attended clown college before
dropping out to pursue a career in
politics
is that true is that is that i mean
listen
let's look that up uh
think people make edits to my wikipedia
page all the time and some of them are
really really funny
um oh man it looks like a whole bunch of
really weird edits were made let's see
this could be really scary
let's look at view history oh my god
there's an edit war happening
what is going on right here holy [ __ ]
oh my god okay let's see let's just look
at what some p this is so funny people
are arguing about me on wikipedia let's
see what's happening
okay so someone removed that i'm an
academic
okay that's fair i don't think i am uh
i'm trying to see what's what's the
explanation for that
oh academic title hasn't been earned
he's clearly a pundit and a very
intelligent person but adjunct teaching
with a master's degree doesn't make one
an academic i agree with that i agree
with that i don't think it should say
academic
i don't know who who originally put that
in this is funny
um let's see party left wing independent
unregistered was simplified to
independent that seems fair
see what else we've got um
notability okay these seem like
technical things that i don't understand
i think we'll skip over them
uh citation needed was added
some reference was removed all right a
lot of little things going on
i'm looking for like the big craziness
some dates were added it looks like a
lot of kind of cleanup
um
huh so a whole bunch argentinian
american political pundit was removed
i've appeared batman also appeared man
this is crazy
i don't even understand why a lot of
this stuff like i just don't really
understand these this stuff
they added that i was an adjunct at
boston college yeah i really don't know
if these are like formatting things or
what's going on
um a citation was removed okay
citation was re-added this is crazy
it was removed that i came to the u.s at
age five
okay i don't know why i mean that seems
relevant i don't know
internet talk [ __ ] political pundit was
removed i'm no longer a pundit nor an
analyst i'm now just a talk show host
okay seems like a downgrade i've been
demoted um
some citations were removed a lot of
this seems very very
minor this looks like another formatting
thing
oh wait what's down here
misspellings were added that's
interesting
okay this doesn't i'm honestly
this doesn't seem good guys i'm not
gonna lie if there's actually wikipedia
editors
watching i would love it if someone
could go back in and really clean a lot
of this stuff
up another entire section is removed
and then added somewhere else with just
like endless site this is bad
i don't know like i don't edit it
because i know that it's supposed to be
neutral so if i'm participating that
seems bad
um stuff was removed about my show i i
don't
this is this is weird youtube was added
back in
okay
technical stuff that i don't understand
and then reversed like things seem to be
done and then reversed so stuff that was
taken away a few edits ago was added
back in
um looks like another reference to me
being argentinian was removed why
someone would remove that i don't know
uh and that's the end of it all right
well that seems like there's a big war
being
oh my god trump speaks radicals
and extremists trying to shut down your
industry and to make america
subservient to foreign
let's go with this audio here this is
crazy
an extremist trying to shut down your
industry is
[Applause]
he's dripping in water and there seems
to be either a fog machine or steam all
around him his mic's not even
on we will never let anyone put
american energy out of business which is
what they'd like to do
he will never again be reliant on
hostile foreign suppliers
we will defend your jobs we will defend
the lone star
state i love this state and we will
become americans
we found energy independence
before going any further i want to
provide you with a brief
update on our battle against the
china virus our hearts are with the
people of texas
we love our people we love our country
statewide the percent of patients
testing positive
has stabilized and the number of new
cases
has begun to substantially decline
but texans must remain vigilant
to protect our seniors my administration
has deployed personal protective
equipment
and rapid point-of-care testing systems
to every medicare and medicaid certified
nursing home
in your state no matter where you go how
terrible is the production value on this
thing
those are receiving 500 cases of
anti-viral
treatment remdessevier it's been very
very successful
enough to treat 3200 patients
under my administration's operation warp
speed
we're developing vaccines in record time
earlier this week a promising vaccine
entered the final stage of clinical
trials
long ahead of schedule with more
following
very quickly behind we have some of the
greatest companies labs in the world
doing this
this is the fastest a vaccine has
ever been developed
has nothing to do with trump
[Applause]
together we will end the plague from
china we will defeat the virus
i want to thank everyone at double eagle
energy
for hosting us today including
co-founders two great
young smart people cody campbell and
john sellers thank you cody thank you
john thank you
good job
thanks also to interior secretary david
bernhardt david thank you
energy secretary dan roilette texas has
keep
really kept him very busy where's dan
you've been kept very busy very busy
a great senator and a great friend of
mine senator ted cruz
oh good good thank you don't tell me
he's out there fighting for you i want
to tell you
thank you ted representatives and these
are friends of mine and their warriors
jody arrington and mike conaway thank
you fellas
thank you thank you
great job a very very special man
and a very special talent and governor
greg
abbott horrible thank you terrible thank
you greg great job you doing
and he's working hard and you're doing a
fantastic job
our people are working together and
you're getting everything you need so
good thank you for doing such a good job
and thank also
dan patrick your lieutenant governor my
friend thank you very much
absolutely terrible person great help
great team no better team in the country
thank you hard to imagine woodland
county judge
terry johnson thank you terry thank you
your former governor a great man a
friend of mine
secretary of energy rick perry nobody
did a better job than my rick
thank you rick that's obviously not true
and we have so many other distinguished
guests and local leaders and we just
want to thank you all for being here
thank you all very much great honor
thank you very much for being here
under the last administration america's
energy industry was
under relentless and unceasing attack
you know that
but the day i took the oath of office we
ended remember the other day trump said
he saved tens of millions of energy jobs
there's only six million energy jobs in
the u.s let's see if he refreshes that
line
the salt the assault you've seen what's
going on it could come again but
i have a very strong feeling you're not
gonna have to worry about it
if you do you're in big big trouble
i withdrew from the one-sided energy
destroying
paris climate accord it was a disaster
imagine cheering for that it cost us
billions of dollars and it would have
made us a non-competitive nation
we canceled the obama administration's
job-crushing clean power plan you know
what
it was against cancel culture i approved
the keystone
xl and the dakota access pipelines
immediately
upon assuming office we opened up anwar
in alaska to energy exploration
ended the moratorium on coal leasing on
federal lands
and reopened public lands and offshore
areas
to oil and gas exploration that's where
david bernard's done such a great job
thanks david we unlock the full energy
potential of texas and new mexico
and new mexico we're proud that we've
been here we're proud to help
you have been fantastic a lot of jobs
and since my election oil and gas
production in the permian basin
has more than doubled
okay under the trump administration the
united states has increased oil
production by
3.1 million barrels per day that's some
number
never been anything like that number for
the first time
in nearly 70 years we have become a net
energy exporter
[Applause]
and the united states is now the number
one producer of oil and natural gas on
the face of the earth
to ensure we maintain this dominant
position
long into the future we will never lose
this position
my administration is announcing today
that export authorizations for american
liquefied natural gas oh no can now be
extended through
the year 2050.
[Applause]
mr governor is that long enough okay
2050 that seems like a long time
he said let's make it longer at the same
time we're strongly protecting our
environment
air pollution is down significantly
since i took office
while other countries are polluting the
world it's down because of coronavirus
that's the crazy thing
he's he's made it easier to pollute it
he just he happened to have coronavirus
which shut down so many
pollution-creating uh elements
people don't know that about us we love
our environment
under my administration the united
states will continue to have among the
cleanest
air and cleanest water anywhere on earth
and that's what we have
thanks to our pro-american energy
policies
we're also taking jobs and factories
away from
countries with poor environmental
standards such as china
and bringing jobs back to america where
they belong
before the invisible enemy struck our
shores we created
800 000 new energy jobs a third of them
in texas that was just the new jobs add
on to that
millions of other jobs after the china
virus struck we
implemented historic economic relief
relief when oil crashed i got saudi
arabia
russia and others to cut nearly 10
million barrels a day
and got opec plus and mexico
to agree to the deal and hence we're
okay now we're back i have no idea what
i'm reading
and i will tell you and i can tell you
that i spoke with dan and greg
and i spoke with senator ted cruz i
spoke with a lot of people
and we were very close to losing a very
powerful
great industry and we did a job we did a
great job all together working together
a job like i think nobody could have
done and now we're back and now we're
just going to keep expanding it's going
to see you will see
it's happening but we really did we did
a great job and i want to thank frankly
saudi arabia i want to thank russia i
want to thank mexico
shocking i don't want to thank opec as
they call it plus it's called opec plus
that's opec plus a lot of other
countries
but they all came together and they did
a job for the industry and
we uh we appreciate everybody's help
this action
stabilized world oil prices that had
been in a free fall
and saved millions of energy jobs and
frankly it saved your industry four
months ago people were very very
concerned
about that industry and now it's just
going to be a
question of how fast will you put people
on through the paycheck protection
program
we provided over 1 billion dollars in
emergency aid
to keep texas energy workers on the
payroll we kept them all on the payroll
we opened up 30 million barrels of space
and
strategic petroleum reserve allowing
american companies to store
surplus oil to be sold at a later time
and we filled up our 75
million barrels in the strategic reserve
and dan you've done a fantastic job on
that thank you very much
i only wish he bought it when the oil
was selling for zero
and they paid you 37 in addition
you get a barrel plus 37. i said damn
dealer but you did well
thank you very much today i'm taking
another bold action to support
energy jobs in texas in a few moments i
will sign
four critical permits granting approval
to vital pipeline
and railway infrastructure on our
nation's border
that's a big deal this will include two
permits allowing the export
of texas crude to mexico a giant victory
for
the workers of the state that you've
been also sign a permit to let greg
abbott remodel his kitchen too just
while he's there you've been after that
one for many years i said what do i know
about it if you want to do it it's okay
with me
and we're doing it so that's been a long
time in the making
we're joined today by some of the
incredible patriots of the texas oil and
gas industry
who are benefiting from america's energy
boom
josh ginn was born and raised right here
in odessa and midland where's josh
thank you josh after spending a few
years away at school josh came back home
to west texas
josh's dad worked on the oil rigs josh
worked on the oil rigs
and he hopes his three children will
work one day
doing the same kind of incredible work
and looking for the
wonderful opportunities in american
energy josh
thank you very much congratulate your
family you're gonna have a great future
thank you congratulations
[Applause]
brian welch spent five years
in the army supporting our victory in
the gulf war
then he became hello brian
[Music]
thank you brian then he became an energy
worker did you make the right move brian
i think so right
better believe it with over 25 years of
experience brian as senior pumper
with double eagle energy do they treat
you well
they better they better i'm going to
come back and see those two guys
just like thousands of other veterans
who work in this industry brian has made
america safer
with his service and now he's helping
keep us secure by maintaining
american energy independence which we
have
thank you very much brian great job
de bryan every veteran who works in the
american energy sector we salute your
noble service
and we thank you very much we thank you
very much everybody thank you
while my administration is fighting for
workers like you
the radical left have you ever heard of
the radical left brian you don't want to
hear about them
only from you you don't want to know
about them is fighting to abolish
american energy
destroy the oil and gas industries and
wipe out your jobs
well we want clean energy is what we're
fighting for really
representative ocasio-cortez's nearly
100 trillion dollar
green new deal disaster
i've added the fourth word it's a
disaster which would ban
oil and gas leasing on all federal lands
and by the way there'd be no fracking
so let me ask you mr governor sounds
pretty good in texas no fracking
no drilling no oil is that okay good i
don't think biden's gonna do too well in
texas
he's already written shockingly he may
be within a point or two of trump on
election day which would be
insane politicians ever get into power
they will demolish
not only your industry but the entire
u.s economy their stated agenda includes
rejoining
the paris climate accord spending
billions and billions of dollars
in order to make us non-competitive and
seek in an even higher level
of restrictions mandating net zero
carbon emissions which frankly is
impossible
sounds pretty good all new homes offices
and buildings by 230
at least as a goal to do and if you ever
did it
it would cost so much that your home
would be valueless
this would cause the cost of
construction to skyrocket and
effectively
end the use of natural gas in homes
because it would be an impossible
situation
they're asking for things just so you
understand
that are impossible i don't know i
haven't checked recently
what have they done with cows remember
there were going to be no more cows and
no more cattle
i think they might have left that one
off the manifesto but
it'll be back there kill all cows they
were going to dispose of all cows
and emissions from power plants by 2035
in other words
no drilling no fracking no coal
no shale no gas no oil otherwise this
seems like a great goal right i mean
like okay let's work towards that why
not
careful you know people don't take it
seriously if they got in
you will have no more energy coming out
of the great state of texas out of new
mexico
out of anywhere oklahoma north dakota
name them
pennsylvania pennsylvania funny because
a lot of those places get a lot of
sunlight
and it's really windy in some of those
open plains it seems like they could be
generating a lot of electricity
that's how big it is they want to have
no fracking no nothing
the policies required to implement this
extreme agenda
would mean the death of american
prosperity and the end of the american
middle class
it would mean i think even worse than
that it would destroy our country
i used to say would become another
venezuela same ideology
you would become another venezuelan
event as well the idea that joe biden
has
anything to do with the ideology of
chavez and maduro is
you you would actually have to be
incredibly stupid to believe it and a
lot of charlie kirk's believers
followers actually do believe it thanks
to bit 101 for the twitch sub
doesn't seem to matter they don't have
anything
and it can happen to us all you have to
do is look at portland
look at the agitators look at the
anarchists
in portland and our people have done a
great job in protecting our courthouse
and i told my people
a little while ago if they don't solve
that problem locally very soon
we're going to send in the national
guard and get it solved
very quickly just like we did in
minneapolis and just like we
will do in other places
they want to solve their problem they've
got a very short time to
do it but they'll either solve their
problem or we send in the national guard
okay the u.s energy industry would grind
to a halt
and every single energy producing state
would be plunged into a depression
two million jobs would vanish overnight
in just the state of texas alone
and i think the number is probably greg
a lot higher than 2 million
millions more would disappear in new
mexico and ohio and colorado and
pennsylvania
by imposing these punishing restrictions
and beyond restrictions
the washington radical left crazy
democrats would also send
countless american jobs factories
industries to china
and to other foreign polluting states
they want us to take care of our air but
china doesn't take care of its air
in all fairness india doesn't take care
of its air
russia doesn't take care of its hair but
we do
not on my watch it's not going to happen
i can tell you that
well hopefully you'll be gone soon
because as long as i'm president
we will always put america first
it's very simple very simple
years and years we put other countries
first do we now put america first
as we have seen in cities and towns
across our nation
it's not just texas oil that the radical
democrats want to destroy they want it
it's really weird to be talking about
how
he won't allow shale oil
gas and fracking to be reduced
and yet he's bragging about how much he
cares about clean air like it does
doesn't make sense does it am i missing
something am i the stupid one expect
for the american way of life there is no
way of life ever in history that's been
like
the great american way of life there's
no respect but there is by you
and there is by 95 of our people our
people love our country
and our people love our anthem and they
love our flag remember that
all right the radical f
wants to tear down everything in its way
and in its place they want power for
themselves they want power
hard to believe power trump doesn't want
to uproot and demolish
every american value they want to wipe
away
every trace of religion from national
life
they want to indoctrinate our children
defund our police
abolish the suburbs incite riots
and leave every city at the mercy of the
radical left
abolish the suburbs imagine that it's
not going to happen
and by the way i just ended the rule on
suburbs
you know the suburbs will fight all of
their lives the rule was one sentence
suburbs and have a beautiful home there
will be no more
low-income housing forced in to the
suburbs i abandoned and took away and
just
rescinded the rule it's been going on
for years i've seen conflict no one has
any idea what he's talking about
it's been hell for suburbia
we rescinded the rule three days ago
so enjoy your life ladies and gentlemen
enjoy your life
oh my god the proud people of texas
will never bow kneel or surrender to the
left-wing mob you will always stand tall
and strong for america
everyone here today carries the legacy
of some of the toughest fiercest
and most determined people ever to walk
the face of the earth your ancestors you
know that
you know that generations of texas oil
workers before you
gave every last bit of sweat and heart
and grit
that they had to build up this country
they loved our country they loved our
country so much
they couldn't breathe their pride and
devotion helped raise up
america's cities power our factories
propel our industries sustain our
families supply our military
and fuel america's rise into the
strongest wealthiest
and greatest nation the world has ever
known we are now
at the strongest point militarily
we've ever been due to talk i'll tell
you
ted where is ted i thought there's a
great leader in this stand up again
ted cruz john cornyn big glitch
and our senate and our house
approved 2.5 trillion dollars to rebuild
entirely the united states military
it's now at a point that it's the
strongest it's ever been
a lot of the equipment is still coming
in someone's brand new planes and
missiles and everything you can think of
and i want to thank you ted you're one
of the real leaders and john two the two
of you i appreciate it very much you are
well represented
imagine thinking ted cruz is good we
have the greatest equipment on earth we
have equipment that i can't even tell
you about
you don't want to know about it frankly
and hopefully we never have to use it
now it's your turn to help lead our
nation to
even greater heights today we give
thanks for
each and every one of you and we are
telling the washington politicians
trying to abolish american energy
don't mess with texas
and i just want to finish by saying that
i've had a great
relationship with your leaders with your
politicians with all the people in texas
we've had great success the only thing
left for him to do was to identify a
specific black guy in the audience
not only did we win we won quickly and
easily
and now we're leading what we had even
four years ago
i will never let you down i will never
let texas down
and your governor and your lieutenant
governor and your senators they know
that very well
so thank you and thank you very much
greg dan thank you very much ted
thank you great job god bless you and
the great
state of texas god bless you god bless
you
why don't god bless you repetition so on
behalf of every american energy worker i
will now
sign these very important permits
that your governor and your senators
have been after me for a long time to
sign
and they've been after a lot of other
presidents to sign them but they never
were able to get it done but we got it
done
and we got it done for a great state
called texas thank you very much
everybody
wow what a powerful speech from the
president of the united states
he will i mean i'm an idiot i'm kidding
no that's stupid that doesn't make any
sense
the rantings of a madman oh my god ted
cruz just popped into the frame and that
was vile
um what an absolutely horrifying event
nobody wearing masks obviously
um trump's face seems to be melting
looks like they've upgraded him to the
extra large sharpie like i always i use
normal sharpies that seems like an extra
big one
thumbs up his hand oh actually i don't
know that the sharpie's that big it
might just be that his hands are so
small
like for me this is look at how small
the sharpie looks in my
hand and look at how big it looked in
donald trump's hands that's weird
and there it is
[Applause]
got that signature
and handing out a sharpie
and a very very strange event
i will take an opportunity just to
remind you our program is mostly funded
by people who grab memberships at
joinpacman.com
six people have done so so far we have a
goal of 25
this would be a great opportunity to go
to join pacman.com and grab a membership
we do have a coupon code
2020 now as we watch donald trump sign
um what is probably more meaningless
drivel owen
carberry signed up in his new member
number seven
and scott flores is new member number
eight
susan brocchini is new member number
nine
and marcus in them is new member number
10 as donald trump continues to sign
nicholas trice is new member number 11.
also stefan granvic is new member number
12.
and peter grado is number 13. i think
that catches me up
as donald trump again showing us the ekg
and it is another beautiful beautiful
day
[Music]
a lot of people getting banned today by
the way the ban hammers i see that the
moderators are dropping ban hammers
which is probably warranted
um if you saw what was going on you
would you would probably agree with me
if you are watching on youtube by the
way
please understand we are currently in a
race to a million subscribers
so please do hit that subscribe button
there's 20 000 people watching right now
okay if only a quarter of you are not
yet subscribers
we could knock out 5 000 subscribers
like that the goal is to get to a
million by
election day hopefully the day on which
this clown is removed
imagine clapping for us
more cowboy hats than masks in the crowd
notice that
oh okay we gotta mute because the music
will get us uh
that'll trigger a real problem for me so
we gotta make sure to mute that
what an absolutely insane event what an
absolutely insane event
incredible um next chess stream
yeah i am in a tournament called
pogchamps 2. i don't know when my next
chess training stream will be it may be
with eric rosen or alexander botez but
it should be pretty soon
um nathan shorb has just grabbed a
subscription in his new member number
14.
um very much appreciate that also thanks
to jesse williams who's new member
number 15
on my website very much appreciate that
thank you
um that's going to do it for me i'm
heading directly
into an interview with new zealand
media this is going to be cool i'll be
posting this to my youtube channel soon
um i know pat is standing by for me
don't worry pat i'm not rushing
but the the stream is is just concluding
at this point
and i'll have more information about
that for you guys coming up very very
soon talk to everybody soon hit
subscribe and follow on the way out it's
free
you